you are
[Applause]
it seemed like nothing could go wrong at
the Scripps National Spelling Bee last
night for the first time eight
exceptional kids became co-champions
after the event literally ran out of
words to challenge them organizers call
that group the most phenomenal
assemblage of super spellers in the B's
92 year history
Errol Barnett was there to watch it all
Errol what was it like that's right
all of it Anthony last night was truly
incredible this Bee has never had
anything bigger than a two-way tie but
check it out these top eight spellers
who dug themselves okto champs were
hugging and high-fiving each other in
what were very intense final rounds
announcers called this an unfathomable
yet perfect ending Rajskub ro skov a
frost cop
correct thank you it was a stunning turn
of events so far you are showing this
dictionary who is boss
the Scripps National Spelling Bee final
took a grueling three and a half hours
but eight contestants nailed the last 47
words in five consecutive rounds
shocking the crowd and themselves each
time
organizers cap to be at round 20 the
competition ended just after midnight
keeping contestants up well past their
bedtimes
what do you happen to know what time it
is
the winners rose to the top of a record
562 contestants who showcase sharp
spelling and a sense of humor
sometime Seuss Rika Party has been a
finalist for the past two years how does
it feel to have your family beaming over
you because of what you've done amazing
I just really can't believe this is
happening right now now Erica thanks her
family and her coach for getting her
this far you saw her younger brother
there he actually says he deserves all
the credit so there's some debate there
but each of those winners will get their
own scripts Cup and $50,000 each spelled
EA CH so that's four hundred thousand
dollars total but when we asked them if
they felt that this competition needs to
be more difficult now that more kids do
have coaches and and training sessions
and they all said no it's fine just the
way it is it looked pretty difficult
they just need to get more words hey
Errol do you not have spell hu s ba nd I
don't think any graduations Errol just
got married
congratulations to you Thank You Gayle
thank you - good Congrats arrow